oh
oh wow
in the weeks following the oscar slap
heard round the world
a source tells et that will smith's
friends want him to step back from work
and go to therapy
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television a source explains that while
the king richard starr's actions have
caused embarrassment for some of his
friends and peers his closest pals are
still privately texting him and trying
to be there for him quote they believe
there is a lot of anger in will and his
incident at the oscars is just one way
that it came out they think he needs to
take a break from acting go to therapy
and sort out his issues
this all comes after the oscar winner
slapped chris rock across the face live
on air during the academy awards after
the comedian made this joke about will's
wife jada pinkett smith
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
following the incident will issued a
public apology to chris on instagram
writing that he was out of line and
wrong adding quote i am embarrassed and
my actions were not indicative of the
man i want to be there is no place for
violence in a world of love and kindness
he later announced his resignation from
the academy and in a statement to et the
president of the academy of motion
picture arts and sciences said they had
received and accepted will's resignation
and will continue to move forward with
disciplinary proceedings against him for
violations of the academy's standards of
conduct
but one person who's not judging will
following the big oscar controversy
denzel washington the training day star
and tyler perry were seen talking to the
53 year old actor immediately following
the confrontation and moments later will
gave viewers a little insight into what
they talked about while accepting his
academy award for best actor denzel said
to me a few minutes ago he said at your
highest moment be careful that's when
the devil comes for you
well on saturday denzel attended a
leadership summit in washington d.c
where he broke his silence asking quote
who are we to condemn i don't know all
the ins and outs of the situation but i
know the only solution was prayer the
way i see it
as for chris he continues to receive
praise from his friends including
chelsea handler who opened up to e.t on
the red carpet at the grammys on sunday
i just think chris rock handled himself
with such a plum and it's like such a
pro
and that you know he couldn't have
reacted in a better way like he just
handled it like a professional and it
was a it was a good uh example to all
performers and all comedians how to keep
your cool you know and not be reactive
and actually keep the show moving along
[Music]